À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Après avoir aidé les Mayas
face à l'invasion espagnole...
Non, pardon, nos amis n'ont
pas du tout aidé les Mayas :
ils ont fui l'époque
en laissant tout le monde
se faire massacrer.
Iris, Thomas, Eliot et la Buse
arrivent désormais
dans une nouvelle époque.
Il fait chaud, ici, hein.
Ah, du sable dans mes bottes !
Je déteste ça.
Puis y a rien autour de nous
à part du sable.
Si seulement
je pouvais tuer le sable...
Nous sommes en... Égypte,
il y a précisément...
très longtemps.
Eh ben, Eliot, t'as changé.
Tu fais plus d'efforts ?
Désolé, mais il fait chaud,
et je vois bien
qu'à chaque fois,
vous vous en foutez,
de la date.
Je détecte
des présences humaines
derrière cette dune.
Ah, super !
C'est peut-être enfin mon père.
- Eh, t'en es où...
- Ah, bah non, pas du tout.
- C'est des Égyptiens.
- Attends !
Le mec, il m'envoie un message.
Tu sais ce qu'il me dit ?
Faucon vers la gauche,
serpent, plume, plume.
Ah ouais ?
Et tu lui as répondu quoi ?
Bah, tu me connais,
j'ai le sang chaud.
Je lui envoie : pied, lion,
bonhomme vers la droite.
- Ah oui, t'es comme ça, toi.
- Euh, excusez-moi...
- Eh, sinon, ton fils, ça va ?
- Oh là là...
M'en parle pas, de lui.
Le petit, il reste scotché
sur son papyrus...
Ah, bah, j'ai le même
à la maison.
À notre époque, on avait
des gravures sur des pierres,
ça nous allait très bien.
Excusez-moi...
Là, maintenant, ils sont
absorbés par leur papyrus...
Eh !
Les deux chiures de gouvernail !
Eh, bon, ça va !
Deux secondes, quoi.
Vous voulez quoi ?
Eh ben, on cherche un homme
avec un long manteau blanc...
Bon, si vous voulez
des informations,
faut demander à la reine.
Vous prenez tout droit,
2ème à droite,
4ème sur votre gauche.
Ouais, mais je vois pas
de routes, moi.
Des quoi ?
Non, on parle des dunes.
Vous pouvez pas louper,
c'est la 1ère pyramide.
Vous pensez que la reine
voudra bien nous recevoir ?
Oui, moi, je vous conseille :
vous arrivez, vous vous proposez
comme esclaves sexuels.
Ça marche à chaque coup, ça.
Ouh, cette reine
m'intéresse fortement !
- Oui, entrez.
- Ma chère reine
- Qui êtes-vous ?
- Nous sommes des visiteurs.
Et comme preuve
de bienveillance,
nous vous offrons
cet esclave sexuel.
Tout à fait !
Qui veut mon corps ?
C'est toi, ma coquine ?
Vous m'en direz des nouvelles.
Quel beau morceau ! Viril !
Ça change des brindilles
de mon royaume.
Vous avez toute mon attention.
Reine Cléopâtre, nous cherchons
quelqu'un dans les environs.
Un homme en blouse blanche.
Peut-être...
Ça ne me dit rien !
Maintenant, mon beau mâle,
enlève tes vêtements
et montre-toi ta grosse...
Vous êtes sûre ?
Il a probablement donné
une relique à quelqu'un ici.
Non ! Non, non, non, non !
Ne dites pas ce mot.
L'autre va encore débouler
avec ses énigmes à la con.
On a parlé d'une relique ?
Mais oui !
J'ai ce que vous cherchez.
Elle m'a été donnée
par un dieu en blanc.
J'ai pour mission
de la garder précieusement.
Il vous faudra la mériter.
Voici Imhotep. Un cousin à moi.
Mais non !
Il ne faut pas dire mon nom.
Ça casse le mystère.
Mais il se trouve que j'ai
un chiffre après mon nom.
Celui qui trouve
pourra me suivre...
- 12. C'est Imhotep 12.
- Mais non ! Le mystère !
Il faut garder le mystère.
Bon, bah, voilà, c'est moi,
Imhotep 12.
- Enchanté. KB-28.
- Thomas 54.
Bon, écoutez, comme on peut
récupérer cette relique ?
Comme c'est excitant !
Il suffit de résoudre
les énigmes
que j'ai savamment construites
dans les profondeurs
de cette pyramide.
Au bout du parcours se trouve
ce que vous cherchez.
Parfait !
Vous,
suivez mon cousin flippant.
Et quant à toi, homme viril...
Oh, oui...
On a plein de choses
à se montrer, ma cochonne.
Ça fait combien de temps
qu'on marche, là ?
En plus, je vois rien,
dans ce couloir à la con.
Nous arrivons bientôt
à la 1ère épreuve.
J'en suis très fier.
Personne n'a réussi
à la résoudre.
Vous n'avez aucune chance.
Oh, merde, je suis nulle
en logique...
Eliot, on compte sur toi,
sinon on est foutus.
Ah, bah, merci,
je n'existe même plus.
Nous y voilà !
Pour ouvrir la porte en pierre,
il faut résoudre
la puissante énigme
que j'ai confectionnée.
Eliot, on compte sur toi.
Mais attendez, là,
c'est super simple.
Y a une torche allumée
à gauche de la porte
et une éteinte à droite.
Hop, je prends la torche
de gauche
et j'allume celle de droite.
Quoi ?
- Sympa, la musique, Eliot.
- J'ai pas pu m'en empêcher.
Mais comment vous avez deviné ?
Mais comment c'est possible ?
Ah, je vois !
Un coup de chance.
Ça peut arriver,
même aux plus stupides.
Très bien,
vous pouvez continuer.
De toute façon, vous ne passerez
jamais la 2ème épreuve.
Eh ben, d'ailleurs,
elle est juste devant vous.
- Quoi ? Le couloir, là ?
- Exactement.
Il suffit de traverser
le couloir.
Allez-y.
Ben, OK...
Non, non, non Iris !
Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
- N'importe quoi !
- Bah, quoi ?
Mais t'as failli tomber
dans le trou !
- Mais quel trou ?
- Mais... de quoi parlez-vous ?
- Il n'y a aucun trou.
- Mais regarde devant !
Au sol, la terre,
elle est retournée.
La texture est différente.
A tous les coups, c'est un trou
avec des piques au fond.
Mais pas du tout, allez-y,
marchez droit devant !
Et redevenir la reine
pour mes sujets.
Quoi, mais qui est cette femme
qui vient d'apparaître
au bout du couloir ?
Dame Iris ?
C'est vous, Dame Iris ?
On dirait le retour d'Aliénor.
- Bah, c'est parfait !
- C'est sombre...
- Aliénor !
- Je n'y vois rien.
Aliénor, viens par ici !
Qu'avez-vous dit ?
Je m'approche de vous, là.
Vous allez voir, elle va tomber.
Mais quel est
ce couloir étran...
- Oh, putain !
- Elle a de la chance.
Elle s'est téléportée
avant de tomber
dans les piques au fond.
Mais avec quelle magie
avez-vous déjoué mon piège ?
Je vous l'avais dit,
pour le trou.
Oh, merde, elle est encore
partie avec ma machine !
Allez, Imhotep 12,
on peut avancer, maintenant ?
Tu as une bonne capacité
d'analyse, Thomas.
Oh, c'est rien, ça fait 20 ans
que je joue aux jeux vidéo,
c'est toujours la même chose.
Eh, regardez !
Aliénor a fait tomber les clés.
Ça va peut-être nous servir.
Ça m'étonnerait
que les clés de la geôle
d'une frégate du 18ème siècle
nous soient
d'une quelconque utilité.
J'espère que tout va bien
pour la Buse.
Euh...
C'est quoi, ce truc tout blanc ?
C'est un bain de lait.
Viens me rejoindre.
Ah, c'est étrange.
C'est la 1ère fois que tu prends
un bain de lait ?
C'est la 1ère fois
que je prends un bain.
Oh, c'est quoi, ce truc clair,
sur ma peau ?
- C'est ta peau, justement.
- Je l'avais jamais vue. Oh !
Regarde, le bain,
à cause de moi,
il devient chocolat au lait.
J'ai vu ça chez mes des-amis
les Mayas.
J'adore ton côté sale.
Maintenant, mon cochon,
ce que tu vas faire,
c'est que tu vas me mettre
ton gros...
On met la pièce
en forme de L ici...
Celle en forme de S là...
Et enfin, la longue barre.
- Voilà !
- Quoi ?
- Super, la musique.
- Ça me fait plaisir.
J'en reviens pas !
Mes énigmes !
- Super, on avance.
- Mes précieuses énigmes !
Désolée d'avoir douté de toi,
Thomas.
- Tu t'en sors très bien.
- Euh, merci.
Attention à la tête.
J'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait ça toute ma vie,
sauf que normalement,
j'ai une manette dans les mains.
Dis-moi, Iris,
j'ai une question à te poser.
Je sais.
Pourquoi je t'ai quitté
du jour au lendemain ?
Non, non, non.
Ah, on s'arrête une seconde
pour les flèches.
Je me demandais :
pourquoi t'es sortie
avec quelqu'un comme moi ?
Je vois bien
qu'on n'a rien à voir.
Je suis moche,
je suis pas très intelligent,
j'ai aucune culture générale...
C'est vrai.
Enfin, c'est vrai
qu'on n'a rien à voir.
Je sais pas trop, Thomas.
Y a quelque chose de sincère
au fond de toi
que j'ai jamais vu ailleurs.
Je peux aussi te poser
une question ?
Bien sûr. Vite, sur le côté.
On laisse passer
la grosse boule.
Mais c'est pas possible !
Mais comment...
Pourquoi tu nous suis
dans cette aventure ?
T'es plutôt du genre à éviter
les situations délicates
et à rester chez toi.
C'est vrai
que je suis pas courageux,
mais quand je suis avec toi,
j'ai l'impression
que je peux me dépasser.
Là, je me sens utile
pour la 1ère fois de ma vie.
Je comprends.
- La relique ! Elle est là !
- Merde ! Comment ils ont fait ?
Mais c'est le collier
que mon père m'avait offert
quand j'étais enfant !
Ça brille, mais c'est du toc.
- Je récupère la relique.
- Non, non, attendez !
Il reste encore une énigme.
Écoutez-moi bien.
Vous avez tout le temps
que vous voulez
pour y répondre,
mais une seule proposition,
sinon vous serez enfermés ici.
Qui suis-je ?
Le matin,
je marche sur 4 pattes.
Le midi...
C'est l'Homme.
Allez, la relique.
Mais je viens de l'inventer !
Merde, laissez-moi au moins
terminer mes énigmes !
Il reste encore une épreuve.
Regardez ce grand feu.
Hein ? Voilà !
Il faut rester... une minute
dans les flammes.
Mais n'importe quoi !
Cette épreuve existe pas.
Vous venez de foutre le feu
à des bûches.
Mais pas du tout !
Ah, vous abandonnez, c'est ça ?
Alors pas de relique,
j'ai gagné.
Mais personne peut survivre
dans des flammes,
c'est de la triche, là.
Mais non, je triche pas.
Vous avez perdu, c'est tout.
Bah, si c'est une vraie épreuve,
vous pouvez la surmonter.
Alors allez-y.
Et on s'avoue vaincus.
Oui, c'est une vraie épreuve.
Et regardez.
Et... hop ! Hein !
Bah, maintenant,
il faut attendre une minute.
Je vais gagner. Aïe, aïe !
Bande de losers ! Aïe !
J'arrive plus à respirer !
Signal vital éteint.
Et maintenant,
on prend la relique.
Mes des-amis !
Il faut quitter cet endroit !
Bah, la Buse,
qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Tu fais pas tes jeux sexuels
avec la reine ?
Me parlez plus d'elle !
Elle m'a vidé
de toute mon énergie.
Je vais mourir de fatigue,
si ça continue.
Partons,
avant qu'elle me retrouve !
Elle m'a forcé
pour que je rentre entièrement
mes deux...
Hop, hop, hop,
on veut pas en savoir plus.
La Buse, tu t'es fait abuser.
Eliot, analyse la relique.
Oh, j'aurais bien voulu
connaître la suite, moi.
Analyse.
J'ai trouvé la balise temporelle
à l'intérieur du collier.
Décryptage en cours.
Les données m'indiquent
qu'une dernière balise
se trouve ailleurs,
à une autre époque.
Parfait,
on s'y rend tout de suite.
- Retemporalisation imminente.
- Yes !
- Restez près de moi.
- On va où ?
- Gardes !
- Oh non !
- Capturez-les !
- La folle revient !
Partons, mes des-amis !
Je vous en supplie, partons !
Et voilà !
Tout le monde est bien là ?
Iris, présente.
Je suis avec vous,
mes des-amis.
Nous sommes au complet.
Donc...
- Moi aussi, je suis là, hein.
- Ah, oui...
Donc nous sommes actuellement
au Japon, en 1150,
dans le palais du shogun.
Le sho quoi ? C'est qui ?
Étrangers, que faites-vous
dans mon palais ?
C'est... lui.
Comme quoi,
les nombreuses heures passées
à jouer aux jeux vidéo
peuvent vous sortir
d'une situation délicate.
Ça arrive pas souvent,
mais ça arrive.
Désormais, nos compagnons
se retrouvent
dans l'époque féodale du Japon,
dans le palais
du dirigeant militaire.
Vont-ils retrouver
la 3ème relique
du Docteur Simon ?
À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Nos héros sont à la recherche
de la 3ème relique,
qui leur permettra de retrouver
le Docteur Simon.
Ils arrivent au Japon en 1150.
Je suis déjà allé au Japon
l'été dernier pour mes vacances.
Les gens étaient
d'une gentillesse incroyable.
En même temps, il n'y avait pas
de dangereux guerriers samouraïs
de l'époque féodale.
Je vous laisse
avec la suite de l'aventure,
pendant que je me ressers
un verre.
Répondez !
Que faites-vous ici ?
- Donc c'est lui, le "showgun" ?
- On dit "sho-goune".
Ouais...
Moi, je préfère dire "showgun".
- C'est plus stylé.
- Très bien, "Thomasse".
Ça suffit !
Déjà, ici, on dit "sho-gune".
Mais ça dépend des régions.
Et ensuite, comment êtes-vous
apparus dans mon palais ?
Êtes-vous des esprits ?
Non, on est des des-amis.
Dans ce cas-là...
Samouraïs, tuez-les !
Attendez, attendez.
On est des esprits.
Des amis et des esprits.
Des esprits potes, quoi.
Fort bien !
Dans ce cas,
vous êtes déjà morts,
et vous ne pouvez pas souffrir.
Samouraïs, retuez-les !
Non, non, non ! Non, non !
On cherche un objet.
Un truc
qui vous aurait été donné
par quelqu'un en blouse blanche.
Vous voulez parler de...
la relique ancestrale
confiée par le grand esprit
au manteau aussi blanc
que la cime du mont Fuji ?
Euh... oui.
Pauvres fous !
Jamais je ne vous donnerai
la relique ancestrale
confiée par le grand esprit
au manteau aussi blanc
que la cime du mont Fuji.
Donnez-nous la relique.
Ou alors, je vous tue tous !
Mais de quelle relique
parlez-vous ?
Bah, la relique, quoi !
Le truc dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure.
S'il vous plaît,
il faut être plus précis.
- On a plein de reliques, ici.
- Oh... Bah...
Bah, la relique ancestrale
confiée par...
- Le grand esprit
- Euh... Au manteau...
Oui, y avait "manteau".
Aussi blanc que...
La cime du mont Fuji.
Oh, cette relique ?
C'est non.
Et je vois très bien
ce que vous avez essayé
de faire, d'ailleurs.
- Bien tenté.
- Comment ça ?
Votre ami a essayé
de nous provoquer
en jouant sur notre sens
de l'honneur,
comme si les samouraïs
étaient obligés de répondre
à n'importe quel défi.
J'ai fait ça, moi ?
J'ai seulement dit
que j'allais vous tuer
si vous donniez pas
ce qu'on veut !
Vous nous avez défiés.
C'est tentant, mais non.
Donc, du coup,
si on vous met au défi...
- C'est inutile.
- De nous donner la relique...
Ça ne sert à rien, je vous dis.
Au nom de l'honneur
des samouraïs...
OK, nous acceptons le défi.
Samouraïs, préparez le tournoi !
Ah ouais,
ils ont construit une arène,
et y a déjà des milliers
de gens dans les tribunes !
En une heure.
Bon, quand est-ce
qu'on se bat ?
Bientôt, bientôt.
Écoutez, c'est un tournoi
en trois matchs.
J'ai inscrit Eliot et la Buse
dans les deux 1ers matchs.
Les gagnants des deux combats
s'affronteront
pour le combat final.
Là, on gagne,
et on récupère la relique.
Très bien, donc moi, en fait,
on me demande
même pas de participer, super.
Ah, t'aurais aimé te battre
contre les plus grands guerriers
du Japon ?
Non, non, pas du tout.
Mais j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on me demande.
Ensuite, j'aurais refusé.
Parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on fait.
Et là, tout le monde
aurait été content.
Et bienvenue
dans ce grand tournoi
pour gagner
la relique ancestrale
confiée par le grand esprit
au manteau aussi blanc
que la cime du mont Fuji.
Tout à fait.
Et pour ce 1er match,
nous avons Shigeru le ninja
contre Eliot... l'humain.
Un drôle d'humain,
si je peux me permettre.
Vous pouvez vous le permettre.
Les adversaires se saluent.
Et c'est parti !
Shigeru, le ninja,
sort un shuriken
et le lance
de toutes ses forces.
Thomas !
Le shuriken a rebondi
sur Eliot l'humain.
Le shuriken
s'est malencontreusement planté
dans le torse d'une jeune homme
à côté de la reine.
C'est vraiment pas de chance.
- Thomas, ça va ?
- Iris !
Je dois te dire...
Que tu m'as toujours aimée ?
Oui, je sais.
Euh... Non.
Alors, pas du tout.
Je voulais te dire
autre chose...
Et t'as pas mal,
avec l'étoile de ninja
plantée dans ton cœur ?
Ce qui est planté
dans mon cœur,
c'est mon amour pour toi,
et ton dédain.
Ouais...
T'as pas l'air de trop souffrir,
pour arriver
à faire des métaphores
aussi nazes.
Hein ? Ah ouais !
Bah, en fait, c'est un truc
qui m'a protégé dans ma veste.
Ah, c'est fou !
Les clés d'Aliénor.
Comme quoi, il faut toujours
garder les objets
dans son inventaire,
comme dans Skyrim.
Bon, Thomas, va te cacher
dans les vestiaires.
Mais pourquoi ?
Bah, parce que
même quand tu te bats pas,
tu manques de mourir.
Le jeune homme
qui a manqué de mourir
rentre dans les vestiaires,
tandis que le match reprend !
Shigeru le ninja
saute sur Eliot l'humain.
Il s'accroche à lui et lui donne
des dizaines de coups.
Et il ne s'arrête pas !
Mais Eliot l'humain
ne réagit pas.
Eliot, fais un truc, bon sang !
Allez, bats-toi !
Je ne peux pas
blesser cet humain.
Quoi ?
C'est vrai, c'est contraire
aux lois de la robotique
d'Asimov, c'est ça ?
Non, c'est juste
que je fais des cafés.
Je ne suis pas
un robot de combat.
Mais on s'en fout, de ton café !
Il faut...
Oh, mais attends ! Je sais !
KB-28,
tu peux me servir un truc ?
À votre service, Iris.
Sers à mon ami ninja,
ici présent,
6 L de café brûlant sans tasse
directement dans ses yeux.
6 L de café robusta ultra chaud
servi directement dans vos yeux
pour votre bon plaisir.
Mes yeux ! Mes deux yeux !
Il titube et il tombe...
Par-dessus la 3ème corde !
Un ou deux sucres ?
Shigeru, le ninja, est KO
par brûlure aux yeux !
Quand on vous disait
que les ninjas
n'avaient pas froid aux yeux !
Excellent jeu de mots.
Eliot l'humain
gagne le 1er match !
- Yes, ça a marché !
- Bravo, mon des-ami de fer !
Et...
c'est parti
pour le 2ème match !
Takeshi, le grand samouraï,
la fierté de la nation,
contre la Buse,
le pirate de taille moyenne.
Les adversaires se saluent,
et...
Oh, mon Dieu !
Le pirate de taille moyenne,
ce saligaud,
vient de donner un coup
à Takeshi pendant le salut.
Il a baissé la tête.
Bien sûr, que je le frappe !
Un point de pénalité
pour la Buse.
Je comprends rien, moi.
La Buse, t'as le droit
qu'à trois points de pénalité.
C'est quoi,
des points de pénalité ?
On se bat, là,
ou on invente des mots, ici ?
C'est bon, tu peux y aller,
maintenant.
- Mais fais attention.
- Enfin !
Le pirate de taille moyenne
sort sa hache
et s'élance vers le samouraï,
et...
- Oh, je suis tombée !
- Aliénor ?
- Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Mais où suis-je encore ?
Quelqu'un vient d'apparaître
sur le terrain.
Sors du terrain !
Quoi ?
Qu'avez-vous dit, Dame Iris ?
- Dégage de là !
- Excusez-moi ?
Je suis en train de me battre,
tu vois pas ?
Enfant de putain !
Ouh là !
2ème point de pénalité
pour vulgarité.
Comment osez-vous me parler ?
Je ne suis pas venue ici
pour souffrir, c'est entendu ?
Espèce de gros dégueu...
Et la personne
a disparu du terrain !
C'est très clairement un yokai
qui a été invoqué.
Oui, très clairement.
Les yokai, ces très célèbres
esprits japonais.
Oh !
Je peux me battre, maintenant ?
Aïe aïe aïe...
Tout le monde sait
que l'invocation de yokai
est formellement interdite
par le règlement des tournois
pour gagner des reliques
ancestrales confiées
par des grands esprits
au manteau aussi blanc
que la cime du mont Fuji.
Un coup de poing, un gros mot,
une invocation de yokai,
ça fait trois pénalités.
Il est disqualifié !
- Oh non !
- Disqualifié ?
Ça veut dire que t'as perdu,
la Buse.
Quoi ?
Mais c'est quoi, ce pays
où on peut même pas se battre ?
Et... c'est Takeshi,
le grand samouraï,
la fierté de la nation,
qui gagne !
La finale verra s'affronter
Takeshi le grand samouraï,
la fierté de la nation,
contre Eliot l'hu...
Attendez.
On vient de me donner
une information capitale.
Oh non, quoi, encore ?
Eliot l'humain
n'est pas un humain !
Quoi ?
Mais pourtant,
c'est dans son nom !
Mais si, voyons.
Je suis un humain.
Je fais des trucs d'humain.
Regardez.
Je vais... euh...
manger ce... litchi.
Miam !
Délicieux, ce fructose.
Oh non, t'aurais au moins
pu faire l'effort
d'enlever la peau, avant !
Apparemment, le moment
où 6 L de liquide bouillant
sont sortis du ventre d'Eliot
a mis les arbitres sur la piste.
Pas du tout. Euh...
J'étais en train de...
Euh...
Uriner.
Personnellement, j'ai goûté,
et c'était pas du tout
de l'urine.
- Pourquoi, t'as goûté ?
- Ça va, c'est bon !
C'était pas de l'urine.
Oui, mais quand t'as goûté,
tu croyais
que c'était de l'urine.
C'était pas de l'urine.
Eliot l'humain
n'était pas un humain.
Il est disqualifié !
Eh ben, on est tout pareils,
mon des-ami.
Merde,
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
Je...
Moi ! Moi !
Je le remplace !
Hélas, les femmes sont à peine
des humains aussi.
Quoi ? Il est sérieux, là ?
Seul un homme de votre équipe
qui ne s'est pas encore battu
peut participer à la finale.
Oh non...
Si vous avez personne,
vous perdez immédiatement.
OK, OK...
Alors, avez-vous
un remplaçant ?
Bah oui, on en a un, oui...
Thomas.
"Thomasse" !
Ah, je savais qu'on prononçait
comme ça.
Ah, c'est ballot.
Je l'aimais bien.
J'étais dans les vestiaires
et j'ai entendu mon nom.
Il se passe un truc ?
Il se passe
que le prochain épisode
s'annonce épique.
Un dangereux samouraï
fait face à Thomas,
qui demande de l'aide à sa mère
pour ouvrir
les pots de cornichons.
Quel combat excitant !
Vous découvrirez la fin
du tournoi
de "Ichijitekina Epic".
C'est le nom japonais
de L'Épopée temporelle.